well you impressed a lot of people you
wound up uh in a leadership position in
Massachusetts and then got knighted to
be Mitt Romney's lieutenant governor uh
which I I dare say someone I uh talked
to someone about you in this interview
and they said wow Mitt Romney um history
seems to be very very kind to me in
terms of uh both National leadership but
also what he did in Massachusetts
uh and that that must have been a really
productive feeling time for you and MIT
it was a wonderful it was a wonderful
experience and by the way
um uh Senator Romney is just a genuinely
good person I know a lot of times people
are a little bit cynical about someone
who seems maybe a little bit too good to
be true but he is honestly a very good
person every single day of the week and
and loves his family and loves his
country and is willing to make you know
very difficult decisions for which he's
been partially criticized by a number of
people in order to stand up for
principle so I I have nothing but the
greatest admiration for him and it was a
great experience working with him it is
funny where I feel like mitt now has
morphed into this wholesome grandfather
figure for a lot of people which I'm
sure he is both wholesome and a
grandfather
well yeah do I believe at least 25 maybe
26 grandchildren so I think the answer
is that's exactly who he is yes
um so you then ran for governor as a
republican in a very blue State
um and uh that didn't go your way
uh I feel like
this movement forward in many ways is
tailor-made for someone like you because
you strike me as reasonable policy
oriented moderate Blue State Republican
honestly
I don't know if that's a fair
description well that's well that's
right I mean there there is a whole
category of of Republicans in the
Northeast and when Governor Romney and I
were in office together
um there were Republican Governors
throughout the the Northeast actually in
almost every state and and these are
folks who are generally described as
being socially moderate and and
economically conservative and although
it's not necessary for state level
policies uh I would also say uh that I
personally am a foreign policy
conservative as well I believe that
America should lead that it's Our
obligation to lead but that we shouldn't
lead with Force we should leave lead
with moral character and principle and
that we need to lead with a strong
economy and that strong economy begins
at home so so those those are the
principles that I always felt
comfortable with it's these are
principles that a number of people in
the Northeast feel comfortable with I
can't tell you how many conversations I
have when I say gosh I'm a social
moderate and economic conservative and
everyone says would you please start a
party that's for those folks because
I've never felt like I had a home and I
hope that that's at least partially what
we're doing yeah very very much so you
know Chris Nunu who is a republican Blue
State gov sorry I mean purplish state
but he's a republican he's a moderate
Republican he's like the he's top of
mind for me when you think about these
Northeastern absolutely part of that
model yeah very much so and he's
stepping down not to run again
um which in some ways is very
disappointing it seems like that that
breed of Republican leader is uh in
danger of Disappearing well I think it's
very hard for individuals like that
right now to get even the nomination of
their party in those blue States because
we have as as everyone has seen uh see
the Republican Party become quite
polarized and moderates have been forced
out you know we have seen even a gov
Governor as wildly popular as Charlie
Baker in Massachusetts who was you know
re-elected with 70 percent of the vote
uh in a state where Republicans actually
comprise fewer than 10 percent of the
voters and he was a Republican and he
was being re-elected and his his
popularity ratings were off the chart
but he was in doubt of whether or not he
was actually going to be able to win his
own convention uh because the the party
had shrunk so much and become so extreme
uh that that they didn't they no longer
even approved him of him and approved of
what he was doing within the state so
people like that should be kept in
politics obviously because they're doing
a good job and people like them but the
party the our current party structure
doesn't allow for it
[Music]
YouTube glad you're enjoying the podcast
if you really like it hit subscribe and
then YouTube will notify you every time
we have a bang-up new guest thank you